[Música]
francia aprobó el proyecto de ley que
crea un pase vacunal el nuevo documento
sustituirá al actual pase sanitario que
requería una prueba negativa de qom y 19
para acceder a lugares de ocio ahora
quiénes no están vacunados no podrán
disfrutar plenamente de la vida social
novak djokovic abandonó a australia el
tenista número uno del mundo perdió su
apelación contra la deportación y no
podrá defender su título en el abierto
de australia djokovic dijo que está
decepcionado mientras que el gobierno
celebró la decisión
el ex presidente estadounidense donald
hombre apareció en la escena política
este sábado en el que es considerado un
acto de campaña de cara a las elecciones
de medio término en noviembre el
mandatario insistió sin fundamentos
haber ganado la presidencia en 2020 y
atacó a los demócratas
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos en francia
donde después de largos e interrumpidos
debates la asamblea nacional dio luz
verde a la creación de un pase vacunal
con 215 votos a favor y 58 en contra los
legisladores aprobaron el proyecto de
ley con el que el gobierno busca
reforzar su gestión frente a la pandemia
este llamado pase vacunal sustituirá al
pase sanitario por lo que ya no será
suficiente una prueba negativa de pcr
para entrar a lugares de ocio sino que
habrá que estar completamente inoculado
esto complica la vida a quienes se
rehúsan a recibir el fármaco tal como lo
había mencionado el presidente manuel
macro
el parlamento aprobó después de dos
semanas de debate una decimosegunda
pieza legislativa relativa a la gestión
de la crisis sanitaria con el pase de
vacunación francia dispone de una nueva
herramienta para proteger a nuestros
conciudadanos
y austria planea implementar la
vacunación obligatoria para los mayores
de 18 años a partir de febrero el
anuncio fue hecho por el canciller quien
agregó que desde mediados de marzo la
policía realizará controles aleatorios
para verificar el estado de vacunación
de las personas con multas de hasta 600
euros el mandatario mencionó que la
medida contará con tres fases
dependiendo del resultado durante la
primera escribirán a cada hogar a
recordarles las reglas en la segunda se
enviarán cartas a los dos vacunados y en
la tercera fase se enviará una citación
para aplicar el fármaco con multas de
hasta 3.600 euros para los que no
asistan se espera que el proyecto se
apruebe el jueves
en países bajos miles de personas
protestaron en amsterdam para rechazar
la campaña de vacunación y las medidas
impuestas por el gobierno para frenar el
brote de kobe 19 con música y portando
carteles globos y paraguas los
manifestantes se tomaron las calles y
bloquearon el tráfico las movilizaciones
estuvieron vigiladas por uniformados
para evitar disturbios el gobierno
alivio el bloqueo que había impuesto en
diciembre en negocios no esenciales pero
bares y restaurantes permanecieron
cerrados a medida que los contagios
aumentan en el país
y novak djokovic fue deportado de
australia y no participará en el abierto
de tenis para defender su título de
hecho su futuro como número uno del
mundo en 2022 es incierto pues en los
países donde se juegan los gran slams
exigen a las personas a estar
completamente vacunadas para ingresar a
sus territorios djokovic no podría jugar
en el usopen ni en el wimbledon andrés
granadillo nos amplía
novak djokovic y ya no podrá defender su
título como ganador del abierto de
australia
según las reglas del gran slam la
posición número 1 del cuadro ha sido
ocupada por el afortunado perdedor el
nombre de quien disputará los partidos
organizados para djokovic serán
revelados el lunes la decisión de las
autoridades australianas podría tener
repercusiones en su carrera pues podría
ser vetado por tres años para entrar al
país lo que le impediría disputar de
nuevo el abierto pero en cuanto a la atp
el serbio seguirá siendo el número uno
del mundo los 11 mil puntos que tiene el
tenista en la clasificación general lo
mantendrá en este lugar por el momento
la atp que recomienda la vacunación de
todos sus jugadores
respaldó la decisión del gobierno
australiano
en última instancia las decisiones de
las autoridades legales en materia de
salud pública deben ser respetadas
independientemente de cómo se ha llegado
a este punto novak es uno de nuestros
mayores campeones y su ausencia en el
abierto de australia es una pérdida para
nuestro deporte
pero ante la exigencia de la vacunación
por parte de los países donde se juegan
los gran slams el futuro de djokovic no
se visualiza alentador en eeuu donde se
juega el usopen en londres reino unido
donde se juega wimbledon que exigen la
pauta completa para ingresar si djokovic
existe no vacunarse también podría
perder la oportunidad de competir en
tres de los másters 1000 que se disputan
en eeuu
el expresidente de donald trump regresó
a arizona para su primer mitin político
de 2022 sin fundamentos el magnate
republicano insistió en que ganó las
elecciones de noviembre de 2020 y de
esta forma inició la campaña de su
partido para las elecciones de medio
término en las que se renueva la
totalidad de la cámara de representantes
y un tercio del senado veamos más en el
informe de nuestro enviado especial
arizona de nuestra cadena hermana en
inglés
virginia la jr smith viven en arizona y
se emocionaron cuando donald trump
anunció un mitin de regreso a una zona
cercana acudieron para apoyar a su líder
al que consideran ultrajado
he votado por trump las dos veces y
sabemos que ganó esta última vez tenemos
que decir lo que es verdad recuerdas lo
que le hicieron a jesús por decir la
verdad lo crucificaron lo mismo que le
hicieron a donald trump trataron de
justificarlo no en una cruz sino por lo
que representa pero por standford el
mito de unas elecciones robadas sigue
vivo para muchos republicanos y donald
trump dedicó gran parte de su discurso a
negar su derrota ante joe biden hace 15
meses una persona que viene y tiene
multitudes que van más allá de lo que
cualquier ojo puede ver no hay nadie que
pueda ver el final de esta multitud ese
no es alguien que perdió una elección y
ahora a causa de eso nuestro país está
siendo destruido se desprendió trump
pidió a sus seguidores que ayuden a los
republicanos al menos a los que a él le
agradan a recuperar el control del
congreso en las elecciones de mitad de
período en noviembre necesita volver
necesita reunirnos como país prometió
que iba a hacer eeuu grande de nuevo lo
hizo antes lo va a hacer de nuevo
gestionado y también la campaña
electoral de 2022 comienza en un momento
en el que el presidente joe biden es
impopular en temas como la inflación que
alcanzó el 7% en él último año cuesta el
doble llenar mi camión de gasolina
cuesta el doble llenar mi auto con las
compras la leche el tocino todo es más
caro si quieres remodelar tu casa es más
caro eso es un resultado directo de yo
vaivén desordenando la cadena de
suministros donald trump ha dejado muy
claro que no va a desaparecer del
espectro político en 2022 está buscando
ser de gran influencia para el partido
republicano y en 2024 los seguidores
aquí lo esperan throne buscará una
restauración y para hablar de este tema
saludamos en ciudad de méxico a
guadalupe correa y es profesora de
política y gobierno en george mason
university además es especialista en
relaciones entre méxico y eeuu señora
correa bienvenida france24 estamos
viendo tal vez el inicio de una nueva
campaña a la presidencia por parte de
trump y de ser así sigue gozando de la
misma aceptación que tuvo en 2016
bueno no podrías tener exactamente la
misma porque no tiene el acceso a las
redes sociales a los medios de
comunicación como lo estuvo en ese
entonces en el año 2016 sin embargo si
existe una población un segmento de la
población que realmente lo apoya que
piensa que hubo fraude en las elecciones
y que no se encuentran
satisfechos con los resultados a nivel
económico claro precisamente por la
pandemia la inflación el manejo de la
economía que es muy difícil por las
cuestiones económicas por por la
pandemia en ti pero sí tiene una gran
aceptación y todavía un público muy
nutrido podría
incrementar su apoyo pero recordemos que
el prsc expresidente trump no tiene los
medios de comunicación y las redes
sociales a favor o las tenía hace
algunos y ahora que tanta influencia
sigue teniendo sobre el partido
republicano de cara a las elecciones de
medio término
es difícil es difícil poder entender
esto porque está dentro del partido
republicano hay un segmento que quisiera
tener un personaje tan fuerte como él
pero por el otro está todo en esta tele
excelente intermedia entre los
candidatos van a separarse un poco como
fue el año pasado en realidad esto les
podría ayudar a tener a tener más
adeptos pero en realidad que ellos
quieren es una figura fuerte como trump
es difícil poder medir dentro del
partido republicano hoy por hoy que
tanta aceptación tiene o no de
presidente pero si lo que requieren los
republicanos es una figura fuerte no
sabemos dice a trump u otra persona pero
si hay mucho descontento en una parte de
la sociedad estadounidense muy
importante entonces se quiere un
liderazgo que quiere cambiar con el
actual régimen y que quiere volver al
partido republicano señora guadalupe
correa profesora de política y gobierno
en george mason university muchas
gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
france24 y ustedes también muchas
gracias por sintonizarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]